I found so as you read the book and the
screenplay came to you what was it about
the story that sort of left off for you
and that gave you a visual sense a few
different things originally it was the
language I love the way the adolescent
and it reminded me of high school and
that's a 20-year gap between us and but
if something was true about this it was
honest and then when it got to the mr.
mr. McCarthy scene where people's lives
continue to unfold they have to pay
attention that really struck a chord to
get I I lost my dad about a year before
I read the screenplay so you know a deep
denial and it wasn't really handling
well but when I saw this script I
realized I really identified with with
Greg in his journey because really do
feel like a child no matter when that
happens and and and I so I saw that as a
way to give something so abstract a
shape and and also celebrate movies and
and and and give things to all my
mentors and heroes the Thomas one of the
one of the things I loved about the film
is that Greg is is not a he's not a
show-off
he is a he's very recessive kind of
characters very wry and mischievous and
funny but in a very dry way he doesn't
let it fly out there doesn't let his
freak flag fly in a way was that a key
for you for them yeah well he doesn't
want to impose on anyone you know he
wants to you know because he's afraid of
the reaction that he might get with you
know you know god forbid it would be
less than positive so yeah it just he
reminded me of kind of a lot of the
person that I was in high school in the
way that I might have dealt with the
situation like this it's these emotions
or to sort of abstract to really
understand at that age and so you know
he uses his humor and he just kind of
pushes back all the darkness for as long
as he can until you know this scene
where they're together in the room and
she says she's stopping treatment it's
just kind of you know all comes out at
once and it's too much for him and he
kind of lashes out Olivia there's
obviously a hole it could be a hole over
of movies that that feature girls dying
of diseases girls who we put up on
peddle so for those reasons what was the
key for you to make your character a
little different um just the fact that
um you know she's everything bought her
cancer she's
not a victim she's not a tragic
character and you know a cancer aside
she's a teenage girl that really likes
herself she's not written as as riddled
with any insecurities or she does not
she's not self-hating she's just very
comfortable quietly comfortable yeah
Jesse you mentioned just now outside the
that one of the reasons the the
screenplay is sort of different for you
than lives and the book was you were
able to kind of look at some of these
characters in different ways as opposed
to Greg's point of view which the novel
definitely was talk to us a little bit
more about how you opened up the
screenplay a little bit sure sure yeah
the book is told in the first person and
it's told by this character that you
guys just spent a lot of time with so
you can sort of imagine you know its
flaws in in in its storytelling how
especially you know it's about him
learning to pay attention and he spends
most of the book not being able to pay
attention he gives very partial glimpses
I think of these other characters in his
life and in the movie the movie is much
more in the third-person so to speak we
still hear his voice over but we're
seeing him from without and seeing the
other characters and so I bet we get a
we get a fuller glimpse of them I think
especially Rachel which was also a
character that Alfonso got me thinking
about more and got me filling in her
biography or character more once Alfonso
came on to the project and we continued
developing the script jeremy the the
sort of everybody's got to do everything
at some point but that every independent
film has seemed to kind of really reach
its fruition in this movie everybody was
kind of putting together pieces of the
of the set at various points and then
the the animations in the film which are
so terrific they came about also because
of necessity right yeah I think that you
know the film the script was so
authentic and it was an independent film
and I think that Afonso came to with all
these visual ideas that were ambitious
but but we're designed to be fresh for
iSchool movie but also keep the
authenticity and sometimes those two
things are at odds when you go very
stylized you can kind of enter a world
where you know you're you're through a
filter and I think you know there was
this idea of this balance
how to achieve that but the film was
still very ambitious that you know it
was a little tier one movie and we we
literally the animated scene at the
beginning where the best of times worst
of times that Jesse had written we were
like yeah we're not fun we're not gonna
really shoot this we only got 24 days
and we sort of struggled with it and we
were gonna try and fit it in and and
then at the end we're like well if we
don't get to shoot up maybe we can
animate it we've been working with these
amazing young animators that have been
helping with making all the you know the
imagination things and helping with the
film at the end and and literally
everybody did everything on this film I
mean we were you know carrying set
pieces around doing everything we could
to get it done and there's just a lot of
love and and and you know it turned out
we're happy we're proud what sort of
influences were going on with you
Alfonzo as you were putting the film
together well there's a little John
Hughes I guess because I remember
identifying with Anthony Michael Hall in
Breakfast Club which came out when I
think I was 12 that was exactly the
right age for that movie and I hadn't
really had a movie that spoke to me
directly and then that happened again
with Mean Streets and then that changed
my life forever but but all the other
tones I mean there was I mean there's
two posters in his bedroom 400 blows and
main streets for a reason and The
Archers logo is off on the side and
that's for a reason too so those oh
those are the influences or at least you
know they set the bar so high that all
would be a journey but yeah but other
than that maybe they were the real
journey was trying to see would feel
something while I was making the movie
and hopefully they would translate how
about the casting process let's talk a
little bit upon so about how he came to
Olivia and Thomas Andrew and RJ who's
terrific or did ya or J well the movie
almost fell apart because we had no Earl
two weeks before shooting or something
like that maybe three but Thomas and
Olivia would I saw them early in the
process maybe about a year or six months
before the movie came together and then
fell apart came back together and then
Olivia was the first to be cast I just
loved her the way she she was I loved
how funny she was and and how she
handled all the all the dramatic scenes
without being sentimental or
melodramatic and still very
age-appropriate I liked everything about
her and then it was about finding the
right chemistry
so it didn't it didn't become a love
story it was never gonna go there and
then and then with the third and then
that was Thomas who came over you know
by the end he was auditioning with 30
pages of scenes just to make sure he was
right and then and then they had a
beautiful chemistry now friendship and
then Earl came in at the very last
minute and there's this first movie or
Jake Tyler and he just had such
confidence in the three of them it just
became that beautiful little triptych
and the beautiful energy flow between
them and and that was just right that
was great
Jesse what is the that what was the germ
of the idea for the book how did it come
to you what was the genesis of it well I
just wanted to write a book that was
published after writing two books that
were emphatically not and so I decided
that I wanted to for once write
something funny but I knew that it
couldn't be you know just fluff just
frivolous so I knew it had to be about
something that was not funny at all and
my my grandfather was terminally sick at
the time that I was preparing to write
this this book and I was just thinking a
lot about how the exchanges that you
have the interaction that you have with
someone who may not be around for that
much longer is you always will
recriminate yourself about it that you
that you didn't say the thing that you
wish you would said or you didn't do
this thing that you wished you had done
and you know I was watching my mom go
through this and I was - to some extent
I mean you know I was pretty close with
my grandfather and so I knew if I could
make something funny about that that
would either be a great accomplishment
or I would just be a monster and I don't
know it could go either way still I just
want to also just touch on Olivia Hunter
you guys mapped out Rachel's progression
as in a way right so emotionally and
physically you were always at the right
like curve right we both did research I
had directed a pilot that year before
that involved a lot of research in the
mattel wing the pediatric wing at UCLA
so I got to know a lot of those nurses
and those that those wings like the
Children's Hospital in Pittsburgh that
are designed by teenagers and
and they're the doctors and I met this
wonderful document Peter Shaw who really
we spend a lot of time with the script
and they treat the the patients like
teenagers like young adults not infants
and and they have to say they have a
voice and they have freedom and and and
he we walked through the whole script
and we broke it down into the five
cycles of chemo before at some point
over the course of the movie she would
legally turn 18 so she could had the
right to stop treatment and so we've
just met map everything good we'd shoot
out a sequence so we know where we were
in the cycle and we're in the cycle we
were yeah I went to the same world and
met a girl who had the same leukemia as
Rachel in the movie and then spoke with
her and her dad and her team of doctors
and that was just it really informed my
performance because just even just
watching her and she's just so still and
she completely bald just you when you
bald as a woman I don't know you you
kind of look like a baby again you kind
of just void of any any distinguishing
features which I thought was quite
interesting really helped with yeah
Rachel let's wrap up with you which is
the what's the thing that surprised you
the most about this movie why are you
making it I was making it I think I had
to I was forced to do the DVD commentary
way too early couple weeks ago and I
realized how different I was at the
beginning of the movie and who I was at
the end by the hospital scene but I'm
the hospital scene I yeah
it was I allowed myself I had faith in
the system again I I was enjoying myself
I had so much support everyone was
behind my version of the film and was
only I mean with the first time when I
said I think the ending should be an
abstract film I was so nervous I barely
knew Jeremy and I thought I was gonna
get fired immediately and he just
embraced it and started sending me links
to other abstract uh you know fish and
granola and and I just knew then I was
surrounded by people that we were all
making the same moving this what it
should feel like and this one used to
feel like when I was a kid and why not
and and that and that was and and
humbling when it doesn't work and then
we finished a movie a couple days before
Sundance and the fact that we never
tested it really other than two small
friends and family to feel that it's a
seem to catch in front of all of us and
and to go from 30 people in October to
1400 late January was shocking but I
think people felt the love that went
into it maybe it's something tangible
there
ladies and gentlemen me and Earl and the
dying girl thanks